ja man könnte fast sagen die würzburger
justiz rollt dem wo man klar in den
roten teppich aus wir sehen ihn hinter
uns das hat aber einfach den hintergrund
dass hier wir finden uns auf dem
goodwill ried vor den toren der stadt
das ist ein neuer hochzeitslocation eine
event-location hierhin musste das
landgericht ausweichen weil nur hier die
korona abstandsregeln einzuhalten sind
wir haben hier fünf angeklagte mit
jeweils zwei vorschob
wir haben wachtmeister wir haben
zuschauer zuschauer die vor allen dingen
aus den clan mitgliedern bestehen der
command klaren soll ja tausend
mitglieder haben die auch heute hier
erschienen sind allerdings nicht in
tranche nicht im ferrari oder rolls
royce sondern ganz brav mit vw touran
sie sitzen hier mitte onkel neffen und
so weiter und versuchen ihren
mitgliedern den rücken zu stärken indem
sich die palme gebets verse rezitieren
in den pausen laut halleluja schreien
und in den bevor sie den weg geführt
werden ihre mitglieder ihnen noch raten
jahre ist gut im knast und benimm dich
und die angeklagten tragen ihr
scherflein zu diesen bizarren schauspiel
bar in dem sie die anklage dann mit ein
tränchen quittieren also fast auf
unschuldslamm spielen hatte sagen ja
auch opfer vor gericht aus was kann die
geschädigten von diesem prozess erwarten
ja ein handwerker aus dem raum ruf hat
ganz konkret heute eine kleine
morgengabe zu erwarten ihm will ein
angeklagter 26.500 euro in bar
überreichen als wiedergutmachung für das
falschgeld geschäft mit dem sie ihnen
über den tisch gezogen haben
man kann nur hoffen dass das geld
diesmal nicht aus blüten besteht und
dass es aus ehrlicher arbeit stammt die
verwandten von der familie komani von
den angeklagten wollten dieses geld
übers wochenende beschaffen um damit die
richter auch letztlich hier in dem
verfahren gnädig zu stimmen
muss man sich da aber nicht als richter
dann auch fragen wo das geld diesmal
dann herkommt ich glaube der richter
hier ist ganz froh dass die angeklagten
hier im sinne der prozess effektivität
ein geständnis abgelegt haben und er
sich hier die saalmiete für einige tage
sparen kann man redet hier von ja über
1000 euro pro tag und das ist also
schnell und verschlankt werden kann
dieser prozess
woher das geld kommt na ja man wird
vielleicht gar nicht so genau wissen ist
es jedenfalls im rahmen eines deals den
angeklagten aussicht gestellt wurden ihr
kriegt anderthalb bis dreieinhalb jahre
haft und verschiedene angeklagte hoffen
auch auf eine bewährungsstrafe
das heißt aber nicht unbedingt dass ich
als freie leute raus spazieren können
alle haben noch andere
ermittlungsverfahren am hals nico mann
hat in berlin noch ein verfahren wegen
eines ganz ähnlichen falschgeld deals zu
arbeiten also diese familie diese
angeklagten werden die justiz in
deutschland noch länger beschäftigen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren